When we talked about rational numbers, we
said that they are numbers that can be
written as ratios of integers. Irrational
numbers are numbers that are not rational,
so they are numbers that can't be written
as ratios of integers. We've seen that
rational numbers are either integers or
have decimals that either end or repeat.
Irrational numbers, therefore, have
infinitely long decimals that don't follow
any sort of pattern. Perhaps the most
common way that we run into irrational
numbers is through taking square roots of
numbers that are not perfect squares, just
like we tried to do with the slide
example. There are some other numbers that
have special roles in math and physics
that are also irrational, like the number
E, which is about equal to
2.71828182845... or pi. Please remember
that I have just rounded off these
decimals because I don't want to write any
more numbers, but like all the other
irrational numbers, pi and e have
infinitely many numbers in the decimals
and they do not repeat. So now we've
developed a whole world of numbers that
fit most things that we need to count,
measure, and calculate in every day life.
There are still more types of numbers that
we haven't touched on yet. Let's look at
the whole entire world of numbers just for
a second. Let's start with the natural
numbers, such as 3 and 718. We then went
from the natural numbers to the whole
numbers by adding 0 to that set. And on to
the set of integers by adding the negative
whole numbers. From the integers we get to
rational numbers by creating ratios of
integers with a non-0 denominator. Those
numbers which are not rational are known as
irrational numbers, such as e and pi. They
have infinitely long, non repeating
decimals. Finally, we get to real numbers,
which include the rational and irrational
numbers we have discussed this far.